everyone how's it going I'm Justine
welcome back to my kitchen today we are
going to be making something very
festive for the holiday season I've been
saying that this entire month because
guess what it's finally Christmas and I
am extremely extremely excited because
it is one of my favorite holidays of the
year now one of the things that I love
is leaving cookies and milk out for
Santa because he likes to go to
everyone's house and everybody leaves
him cookies and milk like that's that's
crazy he's he's gonna be really fooled
so I thought for Santa this year I would
make him something very special a nice
little a printed-out so you know it's
real
a mint mocha and some mint chocolate
chip cookies because I love mint and I
think Santa would like mint as well so
we're gonna start off by making the mint
chocolate chip cookies first and while
the cookies bake I'm gonna make the mint
mocha and then things are gonna happen
and then at the end the video will be
like wow it's just seeing you're the
best Baker of them all so for our mint
chocolate chip cookies we're going to
need 1 cup of butter softened
I hate softening the budgeter one butter
- butter in the way if we go
hmm so let's get our dry ingredients
ready so we're going to need one and a
half cups of sugar 1/2 3 and 1/4 cups of
flour spooned and leveled okay oh look
how nice I have never done that in a
single cooking video ever but today I
won't say enough to be a happy man
sounds really creepy 3 and 1/4 3 cups
how many freakin cookies in my making am
i making it for all of the elves and all
of the reindeer too cool teaspoon of
baking soda teaspoon teaspoon one kiss
what did you say them again I wasn't
listening to myself talk 1/2 teaspoon of
salt
looks good
two teaspoons of baking powder one to
one of soda fridge and freezer is this
not something you were supposed to bake
with it's gotta be the same thing well
if it's not and I died if this is my
last video at least I went out this is
how this would be how I would die that's
pathetic
two large eggs plus one egg yolk the one
and also set to like do this stuff
separately but we're just putting
everything in a bowl and making making
it work and a oh shoot wait did it say
it said yolk not white well you're
getting a white you're just not gonna
get any input it doesn't matter like I
try like moderately bit hard and out for
me and immersed in one teaspoon of
peppermint extract more or less to taste
one that smells so good okay that's one
I'm going to add just a little more
because that's actually I'm not Marcus
fine I love mint I freaking love it it's
my favorite ten drops of green food
coloring a one two three four six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve
I also like green let's put in our God
the butter let's put that in
this smells incredible it smells like a
buttery minty delight twelve ounces of
chocolate chips you were 12 ounces I ate
a few that's okay
I probably should have waited until that
butter was not scalding hot to put these
whatever it does anything it doesn't it
just everything is fine everything is
gonna be great
welcome to my kitchen everything is
awesome it's cool to be a part of a team
unless you don't like teams yeah you
know I would definitely suggest
following the directions we're just
gonna pop in a cigarette I think I
screwed up let's go in here we're just
gonna she's gonna give it another little
beat this was the only thing that I was
looking forward to today was making
cookies for Santa I think I've already
screwed it up okay everything is locked
and loaded
and we're gonna stir it up we're gonna
salvage this mess it's the last thing I
do I'm very happy with what's happening
here
the best thing about making cookies is
eating the cookie dough
listen equipment needs waveform it does
not mean enough
maybe it is
I'm just gonna just talk a mix it up
right this honestly looks like something
that like my dog was crapping out when
he was definitely ill okay you've got
our extreme dark choc no not dark
chocolate it's dark green this is like a
forest green it's something out of my
nightmares but they taste good so that's
a plus I'm going to put these cookies
onto this parchment paper not wax paper
so I roll them into some little balls
that's probably like a nice size cookie
yeah
so when I make my cookies I like to
start from the middle out these look
like Slimer from the ghostbusters it
really does like there's a little oh god
it's looks so gross this is seriously
things that I see on the side of the
road the other dogs have crapped out
this is no longer mint this is turned
into an evergreen diarrhea forest okay
it says we're gonna bake these at 350
for 8 to 10 minutes or until barely
starting to brown on the edges the
center's should be mostly not shiny but
a little shine is okay that's a lot of
things Alexa set a timer for nine
minutes get in there now it's time to
make the peppermint white mocha okay
we'll use Cerrone Josh since it just
gave me ingredients so I'll just put
them all together two cups of
half-and-half and two cups of milk I'm
not gonna do the half and a half because
I don't have it to be honest with you
I've got the milk so I'm basically just
gonna just gonna do some things so
instead of using half-and-half I'm
basically just gonna use milk now the
first thing that I'm gonna do is melt
some of the white chocolate chips into
the bottom of this Cup
that's a lot actually
but since they're not using
half-and-half miscounting not me
we're gonna put this in the microwave
for about 30 seconds start okay well the
glass is warm oh look this is Oh buddy
cool I'm gonna add some milk
okay let's put that milk in there
all right add our green to make it minty
we're gonna add our mint it's like my
hands don't work with my mind and the
shoot that's a lot of mint I hope you're
like mint mommy oh this is like this is
this is like a neon green oh this is it
I had a bowl this is like some sort of
something out of like an alien nightmare
I guess it's fine will Santa like it I
don't know I'm gonna take a sip of it
and just see how it tastes
Oh a bit too much mint in please them
top this off with a nice bit of whipped
cream and our cookies over here cooling
off nicely I wasn't filming when I took
them out of the oven because we had an
emergency and I freaked out and had to
take them out here they are
they look like the Hulk I look they look
like the Hulk they smell good though
okay everything is going quite well
we've got our cooling rack we've got our
mint white chocolate milk now we're
gonna put these on a cooling rack to
cool because they're beautiful I'll
Santa's gonna be like girl come back to
the North Pole with me show mrs. Claus
what's up be like yo check out these
mint diarrhoea cookies that this girl in
Los Angeles California made for me that
mrs. Claus is gonna get all saw save me
like why you bring her here huh why'd
you bring her to the North Pole Santa
these look awful these look disgusting
I'm not even gonna lie but we're gonna
try one carries to the freakin weekend
I'm gonna need you bake them a little
bit longer I think the mint baked out of
it because this doesn't taste like mint
at all nor three tastes good though
Oh God my mouth is what too much Minton
Sandow this one's for you
give us the mrs. clause you'll put her
out of her misery you're quick
thank you guys for watching Merry
Christmas Happy New Year I hope that you
guys have a really lovely holiday if you
don't celebrate Christmas then whatever
it is that you celebrate I hope that you
are spending it with loved ones and not
making this for them because they will
say go away see you guys later
me was Maddie and my phone
we got row with cookie and she's got a
cookie
so obviously
[Music]
you have to work fast before the
chocolate